[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur parlement hebdo
ravi de vous retrouver avec brigitte on
va revenir ensemble sur l'actualité
forte à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat notre invité aujourd'hui c'est
philippe vigier bonjour bonjour c'est
brigitte qui va dresser votre portrait
bonjour steve bonjour philippe vigier
vous êtes député d'eure-et-loir depuis
13 ans vous avez été conseiller régional
du val de loire maire de cloyes sur le
loir pendant 16 ans une constance alors
qu'au parlement vous papillonner de
groupe en groupe depuis 2010 pas moins
de cinq groupes et un passage chez les
non-inscrits vous êtes allé de l'udps et
io constructif udi agir et indépendant
liberté et territoires pour atterrir il
y a quelques jours à peine au modem et
démocrate apparenté ce qui vous arrive à
la majorité dans la vie vous êtes
également pharmaciens biologistes où
vous avez été en avant-garde sur les
tests contre le coc vide alors mais
dites moi en tant que biologiste est ce
que vous vous approuvez l'appel de 75
députés de la majorité à une vaccination
massive
bien sûr que j'appelle à une liquidation
massive on peut pas constater comme cela
que la coville qui a tué puis de 31000
français et bien soit demain sans une
réponse très forte
on va pas se raconter d'histoires entre
nous sur ces accidents se protège
on voit bien avec que la reprise
l'augmentation considérable non des
patients qui sont alors les impacts
valence entre la grille part bien sûr
parce que le sûr mais je dis ça parce
que vous savez capture des polémiques ou
taux des bac 5 qui ont utilisé ce que ne
l'utilisent pas là ce vaccin est en
préparation les phase iii sont passés
les passes 4 sont en cours de
préparation ça veut dire quoi
cirque on devrait l'avoir j'espère en
début d'année prochaine et je fais
partie de ceux qui encourageront mais
plus qu'encourageants je pense que
vraiment dire aux français d'accéder
voulu revenir une seconde sur mon
parcours parce qu' une petite erreur
c'est moi je suis centriste depuis le
début que devait retracer mon parlement
on engagement politique j'étais jeune
démocrate social surtout les prisons du
goupil et y comme vous le savez jusqu'en
2017 et après il ya un groupe qui s'est
constitué que ça peut agir unis dont je
suis parti parce que je ne trouvais pas
mon compte parce qu'ils avaient ce sont
deux décisions qui ont été prises qui
n'était pas celle que j'entendais et
j'ai fondé ce groupe liberté territoire
qui est aujourd'hui dans l'opposition
que vous venez de quitter
qui était minoritaire dans la majorité
jusqu'à quelques jours parce que vous
êtes très experte en la matière et je
les quitte et pourquoi parce que lorsque
sur le discours du premier ministre vous
vous retrouvez minoritaire dans un
groupe parce que je pense que la
situation exige vous venez d'évoquer la
capacité sans sanitaires telles
situations économiques vous avez ce que
s'est passé avec bridgestone la
situation sociale bref à exige que
gérald mais à un moment ou un autre
saturé thema constante lorsque ça va mal
lorsque ça tangue de la même façon que
j'ai été extrêmement solide et avec
nicolas sarkozy
lorsque j'étais député centriste
d'eure-et-loir nouveau centre eh bien je
fais en sorte que là il faut aider le
gouvernement dans le passage que nous
avons pour 2022 ou pas je viens de vous
dire 2002 sera un autre débat vous savez
je crois que francis et 2022 leur
histoire tous les jours les français
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qu'on devient
demain est ce que vous venez dans la
commune va nous affecter
est ce que nos gamins vont perdre leur
boulot justement ce que je regarde les
environs la restriction des activités à
l'école il ya trois-quatre kobe8124 on
va y revenir dans chaque niche appelé
dans l'actualité au parlement le retour
des néonicotinoïdes pour les betteraves
face aux pucerons verts qui provoque la
jaunisse le gouvernement voir rouge est
rétablie temporairement les pesticides
jusqu'en 2023 au sénat semaine
d'auditions très chargé pour la
commission d' enquête sur la coved agnès
buzyn si bête ndiaye ou encore florence
parly ont été entendus pas de mea culpa
du gouvernement sur sa gestion de la
crise nous verrons cela olivier ferrand
soutient la prolongation du régime
transitoire de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu en avril à cause dit il
d'une aggravation de la situation
sanitaire mais les nouvelles mesures
contraignantes
reste pourtant très mal acceptée allez
on débute avec un thème qui occupent
l'assemblée nationale la betterave
sucrière industrie française en péril
[Musique]
en commission les députés de la majorité
viennent d'autoriser à nouveau les
néonicotinoïdes pour la filière de la
betterave sucrière atteintes de jaunisse
elle est menacée de disparaître une
dérogation ciblées et temporaires à
laquelle s'opposent les écologistes
stéphanie des pierres pour sauver ces
betteraves
cet agriculteur va bientôt pouvoir
réutiliser des néonicotinoïdes ces
insecticides tueur d'abeilles sont
interdits en france depuis 2010 8 mai en
commission les députés ont donné leur
feu vert à une dérogation pour la
filière sucrière en suivant le
gouvernement et on dépit des
protestations des écologistes
vous ne parlez pas des 46 mille emplois
qui sont peut-être pour vous des dégâts
collatéraux à cette suppression du texte
la question est de savoir comment on
sécurise les agriculteurs pour que cette
année y plante de la betterave
parce que si cette année il ne plante
pas de betteraves l'année prochaine ce
sont des sucreries qui ferment et là
vous pouvez dire adieu à toute la
filière betterave les défenseurs de
l'environnement sont vent debout contre
toute dérogation les avis scientifiques
sont unanimes ces produits on sait que
ce soit une catastrophe pour
l'environnement sept mille fois plus
costaud plus puissant que le ddt qu'on a
supprimé depuis des années c'est une
véritable bombe atomique
et je vous rappelle que moins de 20%
reste de la plante et que 80 % partent
dans les salles d'eau et les nappes
aujourd'hui vous céder à cette filière
là demain ce sera d'autres c'est une
catastrophe parce que non seulement on
prend du retard mais on aggrave les
problèmes des arguments repris par une
partie de la majorité des députés la
république en marche ont bataillé pour
que la dérogation concerne uniquement
les betteraves et pas les autres
cultures
ils ont finalement eu gain de cause en
revanche les dérogations annuels
pourront bien être donné jusqu'en 2023
et non pas jusqu'en 2022 comme le
souhaitaient certains élus de la
majorité
philippe vigier en 2018 vous avez voté
contre pour donc interdire c'est en 2016
ouais que le vote a eu lieu j'étais dans
ceux qui ont expliqué en tant que
biologiste en tant que député d'un
territoire où il ya des métrages au
moment où il ya plus de quotas comme
vous savez on ferme d'ailleurs des inb
et ravir sucrière en france et que si
elle est plus ce produit là et bien à
partir de là on n'aurait malheureusement
un désastre parce que je suis allé dans
les champs il ya
moi que j'ai écrit à julien de normandie
avec un sénateur derrière avec la mairie
de montgolfier dans mon département pour
expliquer que la catastrophe était
annoncé et parce qu'il ya un autre
problème
j'avais demandé en 2016 je me suis très
bien qui était au banc c'était ségolène
royal à ce que des recherches s'accélère
avec l'inra qu'ont pu se trouver des
produits sionistes de la fesci rien
n'est fait mais rien n'a été fait rien
et l'a surnommé pour peer a été fait
c'est qu'on utilise d'autres produits
qui ne marche pas avec trois fois plus
de quantité que ce que l'on mettait que
les mieux du côté du lit et pire encore
c'est que vous pouvez acheter des
semences de betteraves en belgique
recouvert de nuire du coup d'oeil aux
ide qui n'ont donc pas la jeunesse vous
voyez que ça ne 45 mille emplois
seraient en jeu sur le vif lieu peut pas
on ne peut pas les trouver dans l'agro
écologie
ces emplois mais bien sûr qu'on peut y
trouver mais il faut trouver des
produits de substitution qui marche et
on les a faits dans jeanne et ça fait
déjà mais j'ai la reprenait géré prenais
mes propos dans l'hémicycle j'avais dit
voilà c'est bien en 2018 faut supprimer
c'est peut-être même en 2017 si tenté
que la recherche soit là et prouve qu'il
ya plus d'efficacité
le drame que l'on connaît avec ça c'est
que ce produit qu'on utilise maintenant
à la place des néonicotinoïdes ne
marchaient pas depuis un petit détail
intéressant est ce que oui ou non sur
les betteraves il ya des fleurs oui non
non c'est pas vrai il n'y en a pas un
qui a pas tort le latin abeilles à lever
ou butinent les fleurs
sauf que les pesticides vont quand même
dans la terre dans les racines et vous
savez que c'est dangereux vous êtes
pharmacien biologiste ya pas un risque
sanitaire
alors je vous répondrai simplement
d'abord un si on n'utilise aucun produit
plus rien ne pousse de on a divisé par
10 vous entendez 10 2 fois 5 le taux de
phytosanitaires qu'on utilise dans
l'agriculture
depuis ce qu'on appelle oui je pilote un
village de start up à châteaudun qui
s'appelle les champs du possible où on a
on est des startups à faire en sorte
qu'on sorte de nouveaux concepts de
manière à ce que l'on mette toujours
moins d'intrants toujours moins de
produits
le problème delà des écologistes je
respecte moi je suis plutôt très écolo
mais damas commune vous verrez que vous
êtes un écologiste mais pour les
néonicotinoïdes il faut pas dire ça oui
mais moins que lyon va chauffer mon
école et ils la géothermie
il ya des pistes cyclables y en a 15 km
depuis dix ans
qu'est ce qu'on dirait maintenant qu'est
ce qu'on fait mais les biens en accédant
à la rochelle 2023 et bien c'est très
simple donc plus d'argent
reprenez ce que j'ai déclaré à
l'assemblée s'était quatre ans je
reprenais genou à 85,6 matin j'avais dit
arrêtons le dogmatisme en dix ans
n'utilisent plus rien voilà ça pied
écolos dont il faut plus rien faire vous
pu bouger non on est obligé g salue la
décision du gouvernement de vienne
normandie avoir compris deux façon
transitoire qui va utiliser ce produit
accélérons et j'avais proposé à l'époque
le ministère de la santé
le mystère l'agriculture et les
entreprises que l'on connaît il ya 3-4
dans ce domaine là se mettent autour
d'une table valide un plan de recherche
et comprennent des experts indépendants
qui fasse les validations sous fait ça
si vous avez un chemin ça marchera et
coûte de l'argent
mais oui j'ai sur sa cousine croyait que
le fait que cette année les betteraves
ne puisse pas s'applique pas dans ce
qu'on n'ose pas la boîte de pandore en
réintroduisant nicotine pour les
betteraves
ça peut se trouver sur la vigne ça peut
se trouver dans d'autres récolter car on
n'ouvre pas la boîte de pandore
simplement avec les neuf du côté de
ville monsieur par les défenseurs
nicotine au budget auquel nature avec
tout cela parce qu'on parle des lobbys
un les et les élus seulement d'avoir
cédé au lobby c'est moi les lobbys qui
viennent me dire confiance il faut faire
ça voyez où que vous évoquez je suis
biologiste et pour les médicaments vient
mourir matin midi et soir sujet c'est
pas là le sujet c'est que je veux un
la santé des gens il ya eu des pressions
selon vous n'avez aucune moi je le jure
sur cette décision j'ai tout donné je
suis allé constater par moi-même dans
l'échangé fait les poteaux on a fait les
piles enregistrement vidéo avec les
agriculteurs on a regardé j'ai fait
venir d'ailleurs les fonctionnaires de
la direction des territoires du monde
département il n'y a pas de solution
alternative
j'ai regardé même les protocoles de
traitement des produits de substitution
ce qu'on fait actuellement sans nicotine
est pire que ce que l'on faisait que les
néo voilà la vraie vérité alors les
écolos intégristes de deshors jamais moi
je suis pour une écologie intelligente
et raisonné sur laquelle on peut se
questionner des amish les écologistes
comme le dit le président je suis pas là
pour paraphraser les phrases du
président si vous parlez la 5g a déjà
qu'on mette la 4g chez moi lorsque j'ai
déposé une proposition de loi pour
accélérer le déploiement du new deal en
disons même jia de normandie lors que
c'était il était en responsabilité
secteur là ça n'allait pas assez vite je
le dis avec force que non seulement des
dépenses de caractère centriste hier
centriste aujourd'hui son fils demain un
véritable démocrate
c'est un jour c'est un triste absolument
lorsqu'on est né comme ça dans la haute
loire dans le pays de jacques barrot à
mon avis je pense qu'on est forgé pour
sa vie allez on poursuit cette émission
avec la commission d' enquête sur la
copie de 19 qui continue au sénat
[Musique]
faire toute la lumière sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
les travaux de la commission denquête
qu'ovide se poursuivre au sénat cette
semaine d'anciens et d'actuels membres
de l'exécutif était entendu en phase
avec flora sauvages les larmes d'agnès
buzyn interrogé sur sa gestion de la
crise sanitaire par la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale
l'ancien ministre de la santé tente de
se justifier sans réellement convaincre
le mardi 20 janvier c'est à cette date
que le directeur général de la santé me
dis qu'il ya probablement une
transmission interhumaine
il y à cette époque-là 280 cas et 6
décès 4k exporté hors de chine
et pour moi c'est la bascule à quoi
était occupé l'appareil d'état au mois
de février madame la ministre je ne peux
pas laisser dire que l'appareil d'état
ne s'est pas mis en marche même ligne de
défense pour l'ancien porte parole du
gouvernement si bête ndiaye qui refuse
de reconnaître la moindre défaillance
dans la communication dire la vérité sur
ce qu'on sait et sur ce qu'on ne sait
pas en temps de crise est primordiale et
je crois que c'est ce à quoi nous nous
sommes collectivement attaché dans
l'exécuter que vous sur à oui j'en suis
certaine
la veille la commission denquête
auditionne la ministre des armées
le sénateur de l'oise olivier paccaud de
l'interrogent sur les militaires qui ont
participé à une mission de rapatriement
de citoyens français à one en chine
vous avez affirmé que les dix-huit
militaires qui composaient l'équipage de
l'estérel avait été testé or le colonel
künast devant cet hémicycle infirmer
linverse ayant juré de dire la vérité je
me dois de vous dire que j'ai dit
quelque chose d' inexact le 4 mars à
france 2 donc en effet il n'y a pas eu
de test pcr mais oui il y a bien eu une
surveillance médicale extrêmement
rapprochés mais pour certains sénateurs
de la commission denquête le
gouvernement a refusé de prendre la
menace au sérieux une menace devient
réel
lorsqu'elle est aux portes ou
lorsqu'elle frappe ce qui a eu un déni
dans le pays moi je pourrais vous dire
qu'il ya presque une forme de déni pas
de tout le pays mais d'une partie du
pays il y encore trois semaines dans
notre pays pas de mea culpa de la part
du gouvernement
un gouvernement qui doit rendre des
comptes sur une crise sanitaire dont le
pays n'est pas encore sorti
vigier on l'a entendu très peu de remise
en cause de la part du gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'ils empêchent finalement de
reconnaître ses erreurs
il faut que notre souverain comme vous
savez je suis parti la commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale sur la
gestion des masses est une catastrophe
il ya eu des erreurs vous le dit
aujourd'hui sur les masques j'ai dit
mais quand tu lui c'est simplement une
vie devant nous j'ai posé des questions
très simples des erreurs département de
ceux qui ont fait faire du gel
hydroalcoolique on s'est débrouillé pour
faire des fabriques de masque on s'est
débrouillé pour aller aider le personnel
soignant
il ya un vrai sujet mais c'est pas
nouveau mais proposons pas de
circonstance que vous savez j'ai eu
l'honneur de conduire des travaux sur
une commission d enquête parlementaire
d'accès aux soins les ars sont hautement
déconnecté décalé du terrain voilà nous
avons droit au mensonge 2e rue solo que
j'ai écouté lorsqu'on aura tous les
éléments on pourra y en a déjà pas mal
figé mais moi je n'y songe dire qu'elle
a comme des rats et sur les matches qui
nous ont pas dit toute la vérité bien
sûr ils n'ont pas dit toute la vérité
absolument quand vous entendez florence
parly qui admet avoir menti sur france 2
en disant qu'elle avait testé les
militaires finalement non mais c'est pas
bien il faut dire la vérité il faut
démissionner dans ces cas là en tout cas
c'est pas moi qui forme le gouvernement
pas pourquoi l'état de dire des choses
qui étaient pas juste je pense qu'il
faut dire quelles sont ses faiblesses et
ses fauves c'est dans cette maladie qui
est une maladie terrible
il faut vous dire moi j'ai perdu mon
frère lui colle un médecin donc imaginer
que ça m'a plus impacté directement
donc on apprend aussi tous les jours je
veux dire franchement que sur les par
exemple sur les tests nous le faisons à
châteaudun le laboratoire dans lequel je
travaillais encore un peu parce que
c'est également encore engagé dans la
vie publique dans la vie professionnelle
eh bien on a priorisé parce que tester
tout le monde on peut pas le faire on
n'est pas en capacité de le faire après
les files d'attentes les quiétudes
l'anxiété tout ce qui peut arriver
oui que les gens qui sont symptomatiques
qu'il faut les tester que le personnel
soignant et ça c'est la stratégie du
gouvernement
testez trassanel ont évolué depuis
quelques jours et on essaye
cette stratégie des tests ou pas
aujourd'hui on peut pas faire tout
simplement pour tester focaux derrière
faut des machines et des réactifs et on
n'a pas tout ce qu'il faut pour traiter
justement suffisamment de la chine est
suffisamment réactif sinon vous avez des
délais qui s'allongent ans si vous avez
des contraintes vous prenez l'avion vous
disposez pas un certificat cocof êtes
kobe négative 48 heures avant ce ne sont
ni de pouvoir et en plus pardonnez moi
mais il ya 70% des taux ce qui marche et
à 30% ou il faut dégager l'avion peut
pas tester tout le monde sait quoi on
sera tous je sais les unités collectives
qu'il faut qu'il faut faire mais si on
ne peut pas tester on peut pas tester
tout le monde à l'heure actuelle car
nous n'avons pas les moyens matériels
qui selon en plus ça ne servirait à rien
vous testez les gens symptomatique
il faut tester le personnel soignant et
faute et c'est tout ce qu'on était en
contact avec des patients et éviter
surtout l'explosion à laquelle on arrive
tout dire très changeants franchement
les choses
l'économie doit continuer on peut par
confiner la france ne peut pas se
permettre le luxe dans le confinement ce
n'est pas possible
en revanche principe de précaution
principe de précaution c'est que les
rassemblements où il ya trop de monde
les gens n'ont plus des gestes le baril
a coûté on sortait des de l'hémicycle
donc de l'assemblée cette semaine à
00h30 y avait encore au moins deux ou
trois mille personnes qui étaient sur le
champ de mars
agglutinés les uns avec les autres et un
vrai risque alliaura vrai et c'est là où
il faut faire attention parce que si on
ne le fait pas eh bien il n'ya pas à ce
moment là une pandémie qui se
développent et moi je ne voudrais pas
que on en soit comme ça s'est passé au
printemps dernier à refuser des gens en
réanimation parce qu'on n'avait pas
suffisamment de lits disponibles
je n'oublie pas non plus que dans la
morbidité il ya des gens qui étaient mes
des maladies chroniques qu'on n'a pas pu
soigner qu'on a déprogrammé et donc
c'est pour ça selon vous on n'est pas
prêts là pour la 6 et une nouvelle vague
qu'on n'est pas prêt je n'ai pas dit ça
ils disent ah non j'ai eu des nausées
prêt dès le moment où on priori de
galles et est il en fait c'est quand
vous êtes mal qu on vous soigne sait pas
quand vous n'êtes pas malade quand vous
pouvez avoir le coc vide est
asymptomatique ça veut dire quoi ce
n'est pas de symptômes et on n'est pas
complètement certain que quelqu'un d'à
symptomatique peut transmettre
obligatoire marine résidence ya encore
des incertitudes comme sur le biologique
s'exprime encore la direction générale
de la santé je n'ai pas fait de cadeaux
tout le printemps alors justement j'ai
dit qu'il fallait par exemple sur les
anticorps avoir une réponse
écoutez bien dans toutes les maladies
infectieuses
tout produisent des anticorps
protecteurs sauf une la syphilis quand
vous avez une rubéole vous ne reflètent
pas leurs rôles car vous faites une
toxoplasmose une femme qui a la chance
d'avoir des enfants
on vérifie souvenant les immunisés
contre la rubéole de tout se passe viger
j'aimerais parler aux politiques
je vais parler aux politiques agnès
buzyn était en audition elle semble
renvoyer la balle sur l'administration
le problème simplement vouloir réformer
cette admission
c'est simplement j'ai auditionné le
direction générale de la santé de santé
publique france
oui il faut réorganiser cette
administration la technostructure a
montré ses limites au bout d'un moment
ça demain alors comment ai je cru et
manquer ce qu'on fait et coûteux or la
partie au ministre résident comment on
fait mais d'abord je les adresse j'avais
bien tendres et si j'allais proposé que
les faits soient les seuls patrons de
l'ensemble des services dans un
département
la rs reviennent comme c'était
auparavant sous la tutelle des préfets
premier sujet comme ça au moins des
cirques l'action de l'état elle sera
déclinée de façon identique
deuxièmement et à cette forme
d'administration complètement décalé
voyez le politique s'exprime quand je
parle de l'accès aux soins
c'est la direction générale de l'offre
de soins était pas aussi réticences et
les propulsions nous avons fait
quasiment l'unanimité à l'assemblée et
au sénat dans cette maison on n'en
serait pas là pour la situation
sanitaire donc que les technocrates
descendre sur le terrain qu'ils aillent
voir les patients et ça ira nettement
mieux sinon mieux au jeu ne mâche pas
mes mots parce que franchement j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps dans tout ça
avec engagement
je ne détiens pas la vérité mais au bout
d'un moment quand même il faut se rendre
compte de ce qui se passe le coc vide
comme vous savez il y aura peut-être des
mutations de ce virus donc moi je suis
pas là pour diaboliser les choses
préservons l'économie soigneront ceux
qui doivent l'être protégeons ceux qui
doivent l'être et à partir de là je
pense qu'elle a un qui est souvent sur
le terrain c'est didier rahout il était
au sénat la semaine dernière vous en
pensez quoi vous avez suivi son audition
bien sûr je suis solutions comme j'avais
suivi ces de l'assemblée vous savez en
médecine il ya une chose qui devrait
faire passer comme message très
rapidement c'est une discipline
scientifique mais comme vous savez les
médecins et disent pas toujours la même
chose entre eux raul sur un certain type
de patients ça peut marcher mais ce
n'est pas le système extraordinaire qui
marche dans tous les cas simplement faut
reconnaître cela la guerre vous savez il
ya eu 1 min 36 chloroquine
si chloroquine comment vous en auriez
pas pris de l'hydroxyde je l'aurais pris
si j'avais été tellement touché oui
j'aurais pris mais on sait que ça peut
être efficace non penser que ça peut
être y apprendre et prendre quelque
chose qu'ils peuvent apporter un peu de
confort je l'aurais pris mais je
n'aurais pas appris que ça il ya des
bouquets de médicaments là encore on
avance on évolue mais savez il ya en
médecine il ya eu un très beau film qui
a été tourné à une trentaine d'années
que ça fait 7 morts sur ordonnance m'a
marqué quand j'étais jeune étudiant en
faculté et quelquefois les médecins sont
plutôt en opposition mais là franchement
à l'heure actuelle d'abord à personnel
soignant exemplaires on est plutôt mieux
soigner en france qu'ailleurs on a des
capacités d'accueil encore en réa très
importante
puis voyez le pouvoir politique a fait
en sorte au moins je reconnais olivier
ferrand le fait qu'il ait pris des
choses à bras le corps et qu'on dépasse
la ligne ali et ben on va parler on est
passé on est passé maintenant des
milliers de rennais en france là où avec
5000 parce qu'ils avaient nous explique
que will salas sentir ségur les grands
technocrates 15 jours n'auraient pas de
pandémie
on va parler d' olivier ferrand sur
parlement hebdo on en veut toujours plus
c'est l'heure du plus de la semaine
[Musique]
en commission les députés ont prolongé
le régime transitoire d'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'au mois d'avril pour le
ministre de la santé c'est une nécessité
face à la situation critique que nous
connaissons actuellement on écoute
olivier ferrand nous sommes à un
tournant de la crise sanitaire est plus
qu'un tournant d'ailleurs je parlerai de
d'une croisée des chemins
la croisée des chemins ce n'est pas une
expression pour faire joli c'est la
situation d'un pays qui a été confronté
à une première vague épidémique d'une
violence inouïe et qui a tout fait pour
éviter une réplique un bis repetita
une deuxième vague quelle que soit
l'appellation qu'on voudra lui donner
les indicateurs de suivi épidémiologique
ne sont pas bons dans de nombreux
territoires et ses indicateurs rappelle
à ceux qui l'auraient oublié que cette
épidémie n'est pas derrière nous et que
le virus circule encore parfois de
manière très active
philippe vigier ce qu'on y est à cette
deuxième vague oui on a peut-être qu'on
se raconte des histoires on y est alors
vers la tique une chose puis on teste
puis on trouve des positif est d'accord
on y est ça veut dire faut se protéger
sur par exemple j'appris roland garros
beaucoup d'émoi mille personnes bah oui
vaut peut-être mieux roland-garros mille
personnes plutôt que 5000 avec une vague
considéré rappelez-vous de mulhouse
lorsque il ya eu ce rassemblement
évangélique qui s'était ces mets un peu
partout en france métropole et de
metropolit est née d'outre-mer on nier
ça veut dire qu'une fois de plus je vous
redis les choses avec force
il faut maintenir l'activité économique
de ce pays on ne pourra pas se permettre
de prendre confie n'est absolument une
deuxième fois comme la fois première et
la deuxième chose il faut vraiment que
sur les regroupements
je suis qu'à boucles serrées mariage mon
profil syndicale économique vous êtes
d'accord avec les décisions qui viennent
d'être prises par olivier vers alors sur
les bas par exemple à marseille
d'abord je connais pas ce soir 6
marseillaise
il ya deux choses il ya la décision et
la méthodologie sur la méthodologie
si j'ai bien compris concertation la
concertation a été limitée plutôt je
pense que ça c'est le mauvais chemin une
vraie concertation c'est pas ça qui
vient d'aboutir avec la préfète on a
discuté
comment on allait faire pour tel type
d'association comme on allait faire pour
tel type de manifestation de manière à
ce que l'on puit de cancer organisé les
choses c'est comme ça que ce qu'on soit
vous nous avez rappelé les fonds du
groupe liberté territoire dire si je
suis dans cette démarche des démocrates
c'est parce que je trouve que le premier
ministre est plutôt l écoute de
territoire et à l'heure actuelle sauf
que là ya pas eu de concertation
suffisante selon lui calories de plus
nourris et je fais partie de ceux qui
lui diront et activité économique alors
que l'activité il faut qu'il faut la
préserver parce que sinon ce qui se
passe c'est très dur et donc ses raisons
pour laquelle avant d'en arriver là et
bien il faut prendre des mesures en
amont les mesures en désaccord avec les
mesures qui ont été prises à marseille
évalué la situation précise si j'avais
le niveau de prévalence du virus je sais
pas en tout cas que vous dirigez une
commune qui dans deux mois était confiné
je sais que ça représente pour des élus
pour des artisans pour des commerçants
ne pas pouvoir travailler
donc je souhaite que ce soit vraiment le
plus court possible et vous sur la
méthode
en tout cas le gouvernement doit
progresser mais je dis les choses très
clairement et sur le texte qui va être
discutée prolongeant ce régime
transitoire d'état d'urgence vous en
pensez quoi vous allez le voter je sais
bien qu'on me mêler sacro sainte liberté
individuelle je suis attaché aux
libertés individuelles plus group
liberté territoire est attaché aux
libertés individuelles
mais là il s'agit de protéger si on
protège pas assez c'est commission
denquête derrière pourquoi vous n'avez
pas plus protégé va vous savez il faut
toujours trouver ce qu'on appelle le
être sur le bon chemin on est toujours
sur un vous êtes en accord je suis en
accord mais après je vais vous dire une
chose très simplement pourquoi le mois
d'avril sera peut-être février si la
situation sanitaire on peut pas comme ça
décrété que ce sera pas terminée en
février
mais vous savez vous savez vous non
parce que c'est visiblement voyez la
suède qui était parti sur une stratégie
complètement différente
qu'est ce que s'est passé personne était
masqué personnes étaient était comme
vous savez dépister
ils ont tout laissé faire au bout d'un
moment il ya eu une augmentation pillay
sur tard agression fort honnêtement
quand on regarde la paix la situation
internationale en dehors singapour or
l'amertume en démasquer les appareils
protesté dans les rues partout en dehors
de ce compris des dispositifs drastiques
franchement tout le monde connaît le
même sort moi je suis fan oui je suis un
pragmatique je vois pas comme au mois de
septembre on peut dire si jusqu'au
bateau elle une question sur les
élections régionales départementales qui
doivent se tenir en 2021 est ce qu'il
faut réfléchir envisagé discuter d'un
éventuel report en tout cas dans
quelques semaines fera commencé à
discuter moi qu'il faut avoir un bel
essai des élections aux bonnes dates et
qu'elles ont été prévues lorsque edouard
philippe premier ministre avait réuni
pour les municipales j'avais porter ce
message
et puis il me semble que deux mois avant
on verra où on en est mais en septembre
une fois de plus dire ce qui va se
passer en marche je crois que vous avez
téléchargés ou qu'on soit il faut qu'on
soit les uns et les autres mais
semble-t-il un peu humble dans un monde
en soi où il y aura huit mille personnes
en riant en france pour le coc vide ou
2000 moi je pose des questions est-ce
que la phase 4 du vaccin sera bien
avancée ou alors on n'avance pas voyez
ce que je veux dire
donc il faut aussi s'il me semble-t-il
un peu de pragmatisme
merci philippe vigier merci steve
d'avoir présenté avec moi cette émission
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
c'est la fin de parlement et dont on se
retrouve bien évidemment la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]